aids stands for acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome and the main
causal organism that causes AIDS is
human immunodeficiency virus or HIV
virus so let's look at what is AIDS so
we know that our body is protected by
our immune system so the immune system
is our defense system of country what
aids simply do is weaken our immune
system and once this defense system of a
country is weakened it is susceptible to
terror attacks similarly our immune
system when it is weak in case of HIV
infection it is susceptible to infection
by various other pathogens now the main
cause of AIDS or the main cause of
transmission of AIDS is sex without a
condom or sex with multiple partners so
it is transferred by bodily fluids like
semen etc and also it could be passed
from mother to its baby sharing injected
injecting equipments needles etc can
also cause AIDS but what is the
misconception about transmission of the
disease is it can be transmitted by
insect bites toilet seats no it can't be
because insect bites toilet seats
kissing etcetera etcetera is not causal
of transmission of AIDS and in a
separate video I will be deep discussing
all these topics in details but let's
just look at the rates at which AIDS is
growing day by day at least several
countries all across the world is
heavily affected by AIDS and one of the
top most of the in the list is Africa
and also India is a high-risk zone for
aids aids propagation now the main
causal of AIDS is the HIV virus or more
popularly known as hiv-1 virus because
there are two type of virus each I
one and HIV two now HIV 2 is kind of
restricted to specific West African
population but as hiv-1 virus is one of
the most common viruses that is detected
from AIDS a second patient sample now
HIV virus let's just get a description
of HIV virus HIV virus has its gp120
surface glycoprotein which is important
for the viral entry into the host and we
would look into the mechanism in details
it has its matrix proteins
it has viral genome which is basically
an RNA and it has all the viral enzymes
which comprises of integrase reverse
transcriptase and protease which has
defined function in terms of viral
propagation and generation of new
viruses which we would be discussing
shortly now the first step of viral
entry is binding of the viral surface
glycoprotein gp120 to the cd4 of the t
cell so the T helper cells are the
primary target target of HIV viruses
imagine the HIV virus is just like a
terrorist it is attacking our body and
making the soldiers as a hostage because
cd4 T cells are the soldiers of our body
now they get inside the body of these
soldiers or otherwise the cd8 positive T
cells and grow inside them and in a
process when they butts off they can
even destroy the cd8 positive T cells
and as a result they cause severe harm
to the immune system because the number
of CH cd4 positive T cells is reduced
drastically in AIDS so the first step is
a membrane fusion so it's frankly
speaking the final gp120 exist as a
trimer and apart from gp120 there is
another thing the stalk is made up of
gp41 this whole
surface glycoprotein bind to the cd4
core receptor on the t-cell now before
interaction with that cd4 the
interaction domain for the ccr5
co-receptor on the t-cell surface is
hidden inside a pocket which is revealed
outside when it is interacting with the
cd4 now the interacting domains which is
going to interact with the co receptor
is revealed and now it can interact with
the cxcr4 or ccr5 co-receptor and as a
result there is a fusion of the virus
with the cell with the CD cd4 positive T
cell
this would allow entry of the viral
genetic material inside the t helper
cells and along with the viral genetic
material integrase protease and reverse
transcriptase also get inside first the
reverse transcriptase would reverse
transcribe the viral RNA to our DNA and
this process is known as reverse
transcriptase reverse transcription and
after the reverse transcription the DNA
would be getting inside or integrated
into the host genome by the enzyme
integrase just like the name suggests so
after the HIV genome is integrated the
host genome it would be transcribed just
using the host transcription machinery
and these HIV genome contact contents
several gene segments important genes in
comprises pole gag and envelope the pol
gene encodes for these three important
enzymes that is reverse transcriptase
integrase and protease we already
discussed about the function of reverse
transcriptase and integrase let us talk
about protease because protease is also
very important for viral life cycle
proteus cleaves seven
poly proteins which is important for
viral matrix or the viral glycoprotein
or the capsid assembly so we take an
example of a AG gene the gag gene which
is also known as Group specific antigen
codes for the precursor CAG poly protein
now the gag poly protein is a huge
polypeptide which is in turn cleaved by
protease and that give rise to several
capsid and matrix protein which would
constitute the viral matrix and help to
build up the viral particle other than
gag envelope is coding for GP 160 GP 160
is a precursor for GP 120 which is
further cleaved by Proteus to give rise
to GP 120 which is the main surface
glycoprotein important for HIV viral
entering into the host cell so that is
how we understand the key function of
the genome genomic segments of the HIV
viruses the gag Pol and envelope other
than these important genes they also
have V P Arnn f v v pu etcetera which
all kind of help the virus to disable
the immune system or the detection of
the virus by the immune system so they
have varied function and after all these
things all this processing is happening
the viral particle is getting assembled
onto the membrane the new newly
synthesized genetic material is getting
incorporated and a new virus is ready to
bud off from the surface of the CD a cd4
positive T cell and in the process of
budding off I generally don't harm the T
cell but sometimes of when the viral
load is increased too much budding off
from the cd4 positive T cell also kill
the cd8 cd4 positive T cells and hampers
its normal functionality so in that
respect it can kill the cd4 positive T
cells and there is a drastic reduction
in the cd4 positive helper T cell
population in HIV AIDS patients
now here is an overall summary of the
process we have discussed till now but
what is the treatment of the AIDS what
is the diagnosis of the AIDS now about
diagnosis and treatment I have separate
videos but how can one can stay healthy
when it has AIDS now there is a shuttle
enigma that when you have AIDS you are
kind of isolated and something like that
that gives a mental trauma so AIDS is
normal it's like it it's a disease just
like other viral diseases so there is
nothing to worry about and you can also
make your friend or the person who is
affected making more friendly by
interacting with them and also taking
the medicines which are a combinatorial
therapy that I would be talking in other
video can help to keep that again I mean
increase the lifespan in case of AIDS
and otherwise taking balanced diet
proper exercise and mental support can
help the patients to live longer when
they are affected by AIDS so if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to like share and
subscribe and also comment on the video
to tell me that how do you like my video
and what improvement you want in this
videos thank you